the lien we're here today at the MCM
Expo the London comic-con and we're here
to talk about your voice acting I know
you actually started off studying at NYU
didn't you to be a theatre actor so how
did you move into voice acting well I
want to get out of my UI plunked around
off-broadway and around the United
States working in regional theaters and
after a couple years I was doing a play
I was doing a 4-man version of Romeo and
Juliet and the nurse to my Juliet had
been working in anime dubbing for a
couple of years he's another off working
acne of Crispin Freeman and he sort of
let his anime flag fly during rehearsal
and I was a fan of that kind of stuff
and so after working on the play we got
back to town he knew that I was
interested so at a certain point he I
got a call from him he's like listen
they have open slots do you want to come
and I thought yeah yeah well maybe I can
be a random guy get shot in the head or
something and they gave me a nice juicy
role for my first time out which was
lucky and then it's just sort of
snowballed from there I still did
theater for years alongside of of that
in New York I spent two or three years
still doing theater starting to get my
feet wet in voiceover and then I made
the jump to LA thinking maybe I can
maybe I can make a career this voiceover
thing I don't know and I have but
theater got left behind because I'm a
very full slate but this kind of work
Kaneda mentor I'm a nerd so uh and what
would the teenage Liam have made of that
when you were NY you being a voiceover
actor now the the 19 year old Liam was
very serious serious theater actor he
wasn't going to work in film or TV or
voiceover any of that he was just going
to do plays and then adult Liam had
children and realized he had to buy
diapers and groceries in her head but 12
year old Liam would be ecstatic about
what 36 year old Liam is doing now
because I loved I loved the x-men I
would played an x-men I loved the
Transformers I played a transformer so I
play make-believe everyday and 12 year
old name would have been happy it's not
just boys acting also turned to writing
and directing haven't you how did that
come about and what does that give you
that the acting doesn't well was an
offshoot yeah everything for me I'm
going to
all kinds of stuff now but everything
started in anime and I'd been acting
voice acting for anime for a while and
someone said oh you you're not an idiot
would you like to try writing some of
these scripts I went yeah do you know
how to do that and I lied and said yeah
and then they said oh you're yeah you
really aren't an idiot would you like to
try directing a couple episodes and I
said yeah so from there that led to
directing and polishing scripts for say
Naruto video games and that led to me
getting asked to voice direct on
Resident Evil 5 and now I split I split
my time I mean I spent all of 2011 at
writing meetings and on set for the
mocap set and then as voice director for
Resident Evil 6 it was a year of time
and what I get out of that is I probably
see myself still as an actor first but
as an actor in games and animation you
only know what they tell you when you
show up you're like what Who am I I'm
I'm in love with I'm in love with him no
I hate him
oh I definitely hate him ok and or we're
brothers oh we're I hate him and he's my
brother you find out as you go but as a
director you just have more you're
plugged into the whole project you know
what's going on you know the arc of the
story and it's fulfilling to to have
that much influence and I also just from
my theater days I love actors and I love
spending time with actors so I like you
know trying to work with with friends
and get the performances we need do you
think that gives you real insight that
when you come to the directing as well
having done the acting I think so I mean
I know certainly for games with all of
the I've been shot in the gut reactions
we do for actors who are not as familiar
with work if I have somebody new and I
can be like oh you're really just
flexing your abs and going so I can help
them key in and then forgetting just
performances in the scenes it's you know
it's I know there's slight differences
to theatre and development - voiceover
but really it's just actors sort of work
shopping and figuring stuff out and
that's much my favorite part of
directing what's the difference being
good boys haunting and bad voice I'm
saying it's a hard one to answer I don't
know you know I it's really hard to
predict because I've had actors in who I
thought were going to be amazing on mic
they're just phenomenal actors
and I thought I'll get them on mic and
they'll just continue to be so and but
our flummoxed or don't I don't
understand the genre of the game or just
don't don't have a mic technique yet and
then sometimes they prove me right and
they're phenomenal it's just a weird
little subset of skills and I don't know
why acting like you're stealthily
creeping through it through an alley
when there's nothing around you I don't
know some people plug into it and some
people like what am I do what am i doing
can I can we go to an alley I just I
just you know what when you hear you
know when somebody's comfortable with it
and that's why sometimes you hear some
of the same actors getting used around
town in games because they just they
just get it and it's as a director I
also like to bring in new people a
certain number new people every time
because if it's just the same folk we
all as music director the audience is go
ahead after a while but it's it's just
this this weird little subset of skills
and so when somebody has that you hold
on to them you mentioned of course
you've got massive filmography and
videography with video games with with
animation anime all sorts of stuff I
mean is there a different skill to voice
acting in video games to reciting in
anime and also what does expert how does
experience compare of each there's very
very clear differences when you're
working on any localization whether it's
an animated series from Japan or if it's
a video game from Japan but especially
the animated series the picture exists
they're not changing the mouth shapes
they're not changing any of that so
somebody has taken it which is something
I also do is take in a raw translation
and that sounds like I will kill you
with sword and rewritten it so that it
both sounds good and fun for the
audience the english-speaking audience
but then also matches all that pop up a
Papapa Papapa and if a character is
going you you can't put in the word
cheese there because it doesn't go so
just writing the scripts is difficult
but then as an actor you got to start on
time you got to end on time you got to
make it sound like good shouting or
acting instead of sounding like bad
shatner acting as they go boom
bump-bump of them so it's very very
technical when you're working on games
when you're working on original
animation usually the sky's the limit
there's not there's no picture or if
there is picture it's just a rough
maybe it's you're using motion capture
footage and not worrying about the face
or there's nothing so you can take as
much time as you need or as little time
as you need you can ad-lib more and then
they'll create the picture around what
they've they've laid down so acting for
anime is a lot more technical and of all
the many many things that you didn't so
far which ones really stand out of use
either favorites or memorable moments in
your voice acting career let's see well
the thing that really put me on the map
not my first job or anything but put me
on the map is Gaara from the animated
series Naruto he's really had every
color Under the Sun he started off as a
psychotic little ten-year-old murderer
he shrieked he screamed he was
heartbroken and now I don't know if
you're familiar how familiar are over
the series but as it's gotten on he's
mellowed out he's a good guy and he's
just very relaxed and chill and I I've
loved watching him grow up I didn't know
how huge the wave that this show would
become you know I didn't see that coming
so I loved that I've loved playing
Nightcrawler first and Wolverine in the
x-men then occasionally I'll pop up
somewhere else
he was my favorite x-men boy there's
stuff that I can't talk about that I
won't talk about um another good moment
would be working on the Transformers
games I wasn't a huge part in it but I
couldn't not stop giggling the entire
time I had to there was one line where I
had to say I finally got to say his name
I had to say Optimus lookout talking
about eight times because I'd be like
Optimus you I can't I can't I'm sorry
back to 12 year old Liam was visiting me
in the booth that day what you feel
about having played so many mentally and
stable character the way and also what's
next for you I love I love playing
mentally
save will care because I do play heroes
sometimes and I'll always take them and
I like them and I come with more
sessions because you're the hero so you
have more time the booth but I enjoy
chewing scenery and acting like a nutter
more that's just more it's you know it's
all make-believe so the bigger the
better and what's next I'm going to be
doing some more directing this year
which I can't I can't say what yet but I
start the week I get back I'm on to
animated series that I can't announce
yet one will be coming out in November
one not for a while but is another
childhood childhood dream and more the
same I mean I I never know what I'm
doing two weeks in advance with my
career always were like what am i doing
for the next two months but I always
liken it to Magneto as he walks out and
he makes metal planks come up under his
feet as he goes there they're not
they're ten feet out he just steps
forward and things seemed to go punk
punk punk every once awhile there's a
dry spot I go wait where's the metal but
there it is bunk bunk bunk and go
forward
fantastic well that's a lovely note
expenditure and I've got that fantastic
image in my mind all day no thank you
for that Lear thank you very much
you